how much time should we set aside for
ideation it's a good question the first
question I'd ask how much time do you
have because we have people of all
different
backgrounds I would prefer if you come
to me and you're like Sean my business
owner I want to start creating content I
want to start YouTube I can get you an
hour a week I'm G to work with your hour
I can get you five hours a week I'm
going to work with your five hours and
based on how much time you have is how
we're going to split up your time the
second question is how much are you
executing and how well are you executing
as I actually get to your actual
question I would love to I think we
should increase the amount of time on
strategy thinking
ideation because sometimes it gets a bad
rap like there's that quote that says
success is 1% inspiration and 99%
perspiration you got to put in the work
you got to rise and grind you got to
hustle yeah but also there's a lot of
people who work really really really
really really really hard and the
results suffer they need to be working
smarter more strategic better ideas
better ideation if you have time number
one and if you are executing and and the
results show it you are publishing you
are producing you have momentum even
better if you've got a little bit of
margin a little bit of money a little
bit of momentum well now I would argue
how much time should you set aside for
ideation a lot
and here's what ideation is to me going
for a walk is ideation reading books is
ideation going to cool places on the Las
Vegas Strip and getting inspired as
ideation going to events is ideation
because talking on coffee with canel to
guess is like even though we are
actually creating content right now
there's a lot of things that go into
good ideation many of which don't just
have to do with sitting down in front of
vid IQ or something that helps too you
exper experiencing and immersing
yourself into the world and into the
culture of your viewers you reading
books directly related to your Niche
adjacent to your Niche and unrelated to
your Niche all these different things
create connections between synapses fire
off different neuro Pathways that
Inspire our minds spark our spirits and
help us produce our best content
possible and success might be 1%
inspiration and 99% perspiration but
that 1% pretty dang import important I'm
not a big like manifest things guy sorry
for anybody that's that's respect if
that's your thing like I'm not a big
like Law of Attraction guy
because uh sometimes the idea of that
stuff is like man I was just dreaming it
up and then I saw a car in my driveway
and people who probably really know that
like no no no that's not what it is but
people that literally like I'm just
attracting abundance into my life like
no you're not you're lazy like
ultimately you you you get results by
working however your thought
life
your the book Think and Grow Rich is
true like if you don't think it first
like how you think thoughts become you
know behaviors behaviors become actions
actions become habits well they have to
actually translate so if we do need to
think better and if we think smarter
clearer we come up with better ideas and
the work we put behind those ideas is
better so I hope that's helpful I think
some of the things for ideation can also
produce a lot of Health nature get away
from the computer get in some
conversations with some real people buy
a plane ticket fly to an event and and
and what you come back with a lot of
time is next level ideation you got to
create margin for that if you enjoy this
podcast and are ready for some deep dive
YouTube strategy just go to think
masterclass.com to get access to my
one-hour OnDemand YouTube strategy class
you'll be looking over my shoulder as I
share my best tips and you can watch it
on demand right now at think
masterclass.com